it's time to dust off and reload those
bfgs and jump back into the hellish
world of doom no it's not 2016's doom
I'm talking about the original 1993 doom
co-creator John Romero has released his
first level for the iconic shooter in
two decades Romero sent out a tweet this
morning sharing the level it's his
version of e 1 m8 Phobos anomaly the
final non secret level of the original
dooms first episode an accompanying
readme file describes it as my boss
level replacement for e 1 ma 22 years
later apparently Romero also made this
level in two weeks during his spare time
for a link and instructions on how to
download this new level head to the
article on gamespot and click on the
drop box link be aware that in order to
play this level you'll need your own
copy of doom if you missed out on the
90s and this means nothing to you then
fear not a gory new doom game is
scheduled to launch later this year it's
coming to xbox one playstation 4 and pc
for more on doom and updates on what
john romero does in his free time with
that luxurious hair of his stay tuned to
gamespot